foreign
of like 47 people have sent me this
video being like we need you guys to
react to this video we need your
thoughts on this is this true what's
your take and so Rachel has not seen
this I have seen it and we're going to
get Rachel's kind of blind reaction here
are you ready for this uh I'm not even
gonna set it up I don't even know what's
about to happen so if it's a friend's
clip I'll probably quote it it's a quote
from Notting Hill I'm probably gonna
know this I don't know hot money advice
from social media oh okay get ready
rich people help their kids get perfect
credit scores long before those kiddos
can apply for their own credit card and
it's not even that complicated I can
explain it to you I'm Vivian you're rich
BFF and your favorite Wall Street girly
who you follow for all the money Secrets
as soon as my kid is born I'm gonna set
them up as an authorized user on my
credit card as you can see with the
exception of discover and American
Express most of these credit card
issuers don't have a minimum age
requirement this means I will be issued
a credit card with their name on it but
I'll be responsible for paying the bill
and you're probably wondering what does
a baby need a credit card for they don't
instead of giving the card to them I'm
either gonna cut it or I'm just going to
put it in a safe location I will then
proceed to make on-time payments on my
credit card bill every single month by
doing so I'll start building good credit
for my kid allowing them to leech onto
my good credit by the time they finish
High School they'll have built a credit
history of 18 years and have a score in
the high 700s or even 800s this will
help them rent their first apartment or
qualify for a great credit card of Their
Own oh my gosh you know what I just went
to y'all what if someone watches that on
Instagram and they're terrible with
money they put their kid in this
situation and they don't pay their bills
on time does that mean you just screwed
your kids financial future like ding
ding ding ding that is so scary to me
Vivian I've seen her videos and she does
have some great videos I have seen her
there is some stuff she does sharp young
lady but we don't agree the debt thing
which we don't agree with like anyone on
social media because we're I feel like
we're the only ones that talk about
being debt free for the most part so I
don't agree with all that but like
that's scary to put that out there and
Trust the American culture who has like
average fifteen thousand dollars Rachel
this is what the wealthy do okay this is
what the true Rich are doing to set
their kids literally gave me anxiety I
don't have anxiety I don't really like
the anxiety is not my thing but I just
had it okay that makes me so sad forget
like can I tell you Rachel anytime like
I just I can't I don't trust it and the
fact that yes okay hold on hold I have
so many thoughts okay okay and then and
then B is like you don't need a credit
score right like our thing is like you
shouldn't have a credit card anyways you
don't need a credit score don't be like
trying to like rig the system to get a
good credit score because listen teach
your kid to pay for everything with cash
and then when they went home they can do
manual underwriting and they're fine so
it's unnecessary number one or number
two but number one she's advising people
that most of America is terrible with
with their credit card so like they're
gonna screw their kids right like is
that is that correct am I am I you just
you just uh solved the problem Rachel I
went to the comment section and the very
first comment was like my parents did
this to me and they tamed my credit
score by the time I was 18 because they
mismanaged money
and now it screwed me over okay here's a
question I probably shouldn't even get
into this weight in this water because I
don't know
but like I I've I have known two people
not like really close friends but enough
that they've like shared this with me
that they're that their identity was
stolen from an aunt and uncle that
raised them oh and the uncle took this
right and I know that this is not
stealing your identity but it is weird
that you can put someone's
name
you know
yeah but like
I don't know it creates a whole bunch of
future and potential problems and on
paper you know she's going well yeah if
you do it perfectly it could work out
great for your kid but there's a much
higher probability that you're going to
hurt your kid financially 18 years from
now and that creates resentment and they
go thanks Mom and Dad
oh I would be pissed if I turned 18 and
my parents were like sorry we tried to
help you but we got behind here and
there and now you're you got to dig
yourself out of this hole with this
credit score because you have a really
bad one even though you've done nothing
to it that you didn't do you know how
that's it's frightening that is and you
talk about how to actually raise your
kids when it comes to money in smart
money smart kids and there's a lot of
simple things you can do that don't
involve opening a credit card for a baby
what are we doing America no oh that's
so scary I know so we talk about a lot
on this show but you know you can try to
kind of like beat the system and figure
out what how to do this that that and
that to win
when it comes down to it it is your
behavior what you choose to do with
money is how you're going to win and I
think one of the one of the gifts
parents can give their kids is teach
teach them how do you handle money and
actually show them hey you have to work
we're doing this with our kids are the
two girls at least Charles's
he's three and he just probably will
never run I'll probably just give him
money all the time he's not already
there's just something in my heart about
Charles I'll be like you can just stay
with me forever
but the girls were like okay you know
you got to do you know Caroline's five
now so there they are they're doing
chores and they understand okay if I
work here if I work and do this this and
this that we've very much communicated
then you get money and they're at the
young age where now they're not saving
up for anything they're five and seven
so we get to go to Target or a toy store
here in in Nashville you know and they
get to spend some of their money in a
few weeks and they love it and it's
great and then as they get older you
start to teach them okay now that you
know where money comes from it comes
from work now we're going to give we're
going to save and we're going to spend
here are three things that you can do
with money and under our roof you're
going to practice these things you're
gonna you're gonna make mistakes and
we're gonna allow you to make mistakes
and that's great uh you're gonna get
some victories and a little bit of this
like Dignity of oh wow I did that and
and you can start to see progress It's
that behavior that you want to instill
with your kids because that's what gives
them the dignity when they leave home at
18
that they get to go and win because they
have the knowledge and that's and that's
my story you know people think that some
people do I guess everyone's like well
you know you guys are good with money
because your dad just gives you money
I'm like you think Dave Ramsey like
sends me secret checks in the mail that
would be awesome if he did that would be
great he doesn't but the gift that they
gave us as kids is like understanding
how to do this stuff at 18 and so thank
God you know we were able to avoid debts
and know how to budget know how to save
and we're not perfect with money but
learning those Basics you get to start
that at 18 which is a gift where a lot
of people start you know 30s 40s 50s
even 60s they're way in the hole Yeah
because you know they they didn't know
this stuff
um but man that's the gift you want to
give your kids not trying to like
finagle this this debt playing industry
and how to work it and like no give them
the knowledge and the experience and
that that's what will take them places
absolutely this is and so I covered the
the whole debunking all the credit score
myths that she's talking about you need
a credit score to rent an apartment you
need a credit score and it's just not
true and I'm just tired of us
perpetuating these myths that cause
people to go into debt which by the way
is the only way to create a credit score
and maintain one is to do that and pay
it off perfectly every single Factor has
to do with debt and the problem here is
that it doesn't set your kid up for
financial success they can still be in a
pile of debt when they graduate college
because they have their great credit
score right so if you want to set them
up set up a 529 or an Esa when they when
they're born and do that for 18 years
now that's right that they can go to
school and pay for it because of yes
that's trying to help them start to do a
budget and show them how to manage their
money wisely as they get their first job
and show them that not having debt sets
you up and as we see these new
generations come up I think we're gonna
see that where they go oh gosh they're
stressed out because they have all these
student loans I don't want one of those
yes no thank you well there was a
article that I read a few weeks ago and
they talked about that even within gen z
uh a lot there's like you know I mean
every generation I know has you know the
the good eggs and the bad eggs in the
bunch but how they're they're
interviewing a couple of them they said
well I'm watching my older siblings
Millennials graduate you know with yeah
six figures of debt they're stressed out
because of what's going on when you know
the coveted shutdown happened they
didn't have savings and they're like I
don't want to be that yes and so there
is a little bit of that rebellion of
like whatever that system was at the
millennials to do why and the Boomers
were trying to play like I don't want to
do that so Rachel that's great we just
did a whole episode on Smart money happy
hour called scroll with caution how to
spat bad money advice on social media so
go check that out wherever you listen to
podcasts smart money happy hour just
released yesterday and we do a lot of
reacts to a lot of money advice out
there some hot takes and a lot of laughs
man yeah make sure to check that out
this is the Ramsey Show